[Musica]
[Applauso]
che emozioni vi suscita questa foto che
vedete alle mie spalle
io vedo un tessuto bianco che mi da un
senso di libertà è anche un senso di
leggerezza
eppure con lo stesso tessuto potrebbe
benissimo essere uno dei tantissimi
veliche io a casa
e incredibile come questo tessuto alle
mie spalle
e bello e bianco senso di leggerezza
senso di libertà ma se io prendo quel
tessuto e lo metto addosso ecco che la
libertà diventa oppressione la
leggerezza diventa pesantezza di vento
cupa di vento con la donna che è molto
ovviamente è stata oppressa nella vita è
oppressa
ma io non so niente di tutto ciò
in arabo il vero si chiama
italiano si chiama velo ma c'è ancora
chi nel 2022 lo chiama cosa perché non
fai fa nome lo chiama fazzoletto
c'è chi lo chiama burqa io non ho un
burqa questo si chiama velo e io ci
tengo che le persone utilizzino le
giuste parole per indicare quello che
porto addosso
io in 29 anni della mia vita ho dovuto
fare tante lotte in primis ho dovuto
lottare e difendere il mio velo perché
se c'è chi sceglie
scusate se c'è chi non ha mai scelto di
portare il velo c'è anche chi sceglie di
portarlo e io quando salgo su un palco
pure entrò nella stanza ci sono due cose
che le persone notano in primis il mio
vedo perché non passò
inosservata la seconda cosa invece il
linguaggio
dopo il velo le persone notano appunto
che
che si parla italiano
però prima ancora di
di farvi una domanda molto abbastanza
strong
ci tengo a farvi questa domanda appunto
che cosa vedete quando guardate una
ragazza con il velo
pensateci pochi secondi
cosa vedete c'è chi vede oppressione
sono pochi coloro che vedono libertà
c'è chi vede una donna che non è capace
a fare nulla che non esce di casa che
non viaggia da sola che deve chiedere
perennemente il permesso al marito il
fratello al padre al nonno comunque la
figura maschile
eppure io veramente non sono niente di
tutto questo c'è la seconda cosa che vi
ho detto il linguaggio e c'è una frase
che mi viene sempre detta io vivo in
italia da 22 anni
sono nata in marocco è cresciuta in
italia e c'è una frase non mi fa
particolarmente impazzire che costa
quindi come parli bene l'italiano e io
da buona piemonte esatta rispondo sono
ben ciò che in piemontese significa fan
proprio messi male e l'interlocutore
quando sente questa risposta in
piemontese shock totale che dice questa
è velata parla benissimo italiano si
permette pure di parlare piemontese
quindi immaginate come si crea un
momento di quasi disagio ecco
ma oggi ho fatto questa scelta
oggi mise lo
aspettate
mi svelerò anzini svelo metaforicamente
perché non ho nessuna intenzione di
togliere il velo velo per cui ho tanto
lottato e imi svelerò partendo da quelle
che sono le mie radici
io sono nato a casablanca 29 anni fa e
sono cresciuta nella capitale sabauda a
torino
crescere tra due culture non è facile
perché ti trovi davvero a dover superare
tante difficoltà a dover capire in
primis chi sei sono marocchino sono
italiana furono su mara che cosa sono io
e te ne devi prima di arrivare una
consapevolezza di chi sono i di chi
voglio essere e dove voglio arrivare
ne ho fatta di strada
però ho sempre incontrato quelli quella
parte con la fetta di persone che mi
hanno sempre considerata troppo
marocchina per essere tali no è troppo
italiana per essere marocchina e qui è
come quando devi scegliere
cosa è più buono il cous cous o una
bella pizza io non scelgo per me sono
entrambi dei piatti fantastici
perché devo scegliere e la stessa cosa
di chi mi chiede ma tu che cosa ti senti
ma posso sentirmi tutto come possono
sentirmi niente e mi sento italiana
marocchina cittadina nel mondo mi sento
tutto quello che voglio ma sono io che
scelgo che cosa sentirmi
e poi ci sono i traguardi che ho
raggiunto io sono cresciuto appunto a
torino ho fatto tutte le scuole partendo
proprio dalle elementari medie superiori
università
mi sono laureato in triennale in scienze
della scienza della cooperazione dello
sviluppo poi ho proseguito con la
magistrale con doppio titolo quindi una
b nazionale tra l'italia e il marocco e
arriva la seconda laurea poi c'è il
master quindi tre titoli di studio
ho scelto di tornare in marocco per fare
questo magistrale perché ho passato
tutta la vita qui in italia e ho sentito
da un certo punto della mia vita che
dovevo tornare alle radici perché sono
nato in marocco sono semplicemente
cresciuta qui torno in marocco e
riscoprono la mia parte marocchina
riscopro quelle che sono le mie origini
marocchine ma non è facile vivere in
marocco soprattutto per una persona come
me che è cresciuta in italia e anche lì
c'è un altro stereotipo perché si dà
quasi per scontato che chi è marocchino
come nel mio caso e cresce qui in italia
sia marocchino al cento per cento nel
senso che se voi mi fate delle domande
sul marocco e propositi non vi fa per
rispondere al cento per cento perché
sono cresciuta qui se mi fate le domande
su torino sull'italia credetemi che sono
abbastanza brava su questo
e poi ci sono loro
queste sono
una parte importante della mia vita sono
le amiche quelle che ci sono sempre
state per me è che ci sono tuttora per
me sono quelle amiche che ci sono state
in un periodo buio della mia vita in
prima superiore perché c'è una cosa
molto brutta chiamata bullismo che penso
molti di voi ho molti di noi comunque
hanno subito e io ho subito il bullismo
in prima superiore non per il velo
perché non portava ancora il velo
avevano messo a 18 anni ho subito
bullismo per il semplice fatto che un
nome e cognome diverso mi chiamo cadca
tira mio nome è khan design italiano
abbreviando lo e cadi come cadere sfiga
vuole che al cognome che tira quindi
cadi e tira e si è creata una
barzelletta che sa far ridere a molti e
questa ragazza ha cominciato tutto il
tempo di reca di tira tira di qua ti
radi la cadi per terra
ripetutamente
io ho provato a difendermi dicendole di
smetterla perché non era il caso di
continuare ad insultarmi e poi
all'uscita dalla scuola è successo
quello che succede in tante scuole
purtroppo questo episodio qua per tre
anni della mia vita mia
mi ha messo a disagio perché non mi ha
mai permesso di essere quello che sono
realmente io per tre anni ho dato
importanza è una persona che non mi
conosce e che dimessa solamente il mio
nome ovvero cadi e tira tra l'altro non
fa nemmeno al mio nome perché la briga
tivo
poi mi sono fatta coraggio e quel
coraggio è arrivato sia per un percorso
spirituale che ho fatto ma anche a loro
sono le mie ex compagne delle superiori
e su questo forte c'è una persona qui in
alto che federica la ragazza con il
bellissimo bambino è diventata madre
circa sette mesi fa federica è quella
mica io vi auguro di avere nella vita le
piante e quella persona con cui
condivido tante cose ma non condivido la
fede che federica è pura mente a te al
101 per cento quindi quando parlò di
fede
io sono qua qua e quella media che un
giorno quando io non avevo il coraggio
di indossare il velo perché vi ripeto al
bullismo mia
mia tormentata per anni e quindi mi sono
detta se metto il velo alla scuola dove
mi hanno picchiata
chissà cosa succederà con il velo l'ho
fatto ho messo il vero in quanto
superiore sono tornate in quella scuola
dove sono stata vittima di bullismo
e ho avuto il coraggio di essere me
stessa camminare a testa alta ma è anche
grazie a loro che non mi hanno mai
giudicata che conoscono la vera cadice
perché di carica ce n'è solo una non c'è
la carige italiana alla carica
marocchina da cadice musulmana io sono
tutto questo è oggi voglio ringraziare
federica perché penso che in 17 anni
circa non ho mai fatto quindi fede se lì
in alto grazie per avermi accompagnata
aver creduto in me e per avermi dato
quel coraggio che non avevo che
semplicemente il coraggio di essere se
stessi io sono anche con la ragazza che
in questi anni in circa 12 anni ha
viaggiato il mondo lavorativo per cento
nazionale quindi mi sono appassionata
della cooperazione e l'ho fatto anche
rappresentando diverse volte l'italia
qui era un pakistan mi hanno detto meno
selezionata come partecipante italiana
il mio ha chiesto di portare la bandiera
del paese che rappresentava punto
l'italia molto orgogliosa di tenere il
tricolore come in valigia allo stesso
tempo ho deciso di indossare un vestito
tipico marocchino perché quella in foto
sono quello che sono io italiana
marocchina ma anche musulmana
io sono la stessa ragazza che per circa
sei anni
ha scelto di diventare un libro vivente
che cos'è il libro evidente è un concept
è un concetto la metodologia
dove le persone si trasformano i libri
ma libri viventi quindi di fronte a voi
non avete un libro che dovete leggere
avete una persona in carne ed ossa che
si racconta e lo fa con il form del
libro quindi c'è la copertina c'è
l'indice e poi ci sono tutte le pagine
che sfogliate ecco io per sé anni sono
entrata nelle scuole quindi sono tornata
sempre in quel luogo che mi ha un po
fatto paura per vide il bullismo però
sono entrata in quale scuola anche per
condannare bullismo condannare razzismo
islamofobia tutto quello che di negativo
conosciamo ecco e ogni volta che entrò
nelle classi ho paura il premo perché
non so mai che domande mi faranno gli
studenti e le studentesse
fanno delle domande che non sono banali
che non so nemmeno stupide perché
secondo me non ci sono domande stupide
tutte le cito finché si rispettano la
persona che si vada avanti
e ci sono quello domande tipo ma tu
dormi con il velo
ti fai la doccia con il velo ma no
continuerai ne ho più di 100 tanti
colori ogni stagione i suoi colori e
questo è uno dei feedback più belli che
ho ricevuto da una seconda superiore
dove appunto mi hanno detto grazie per
aver portato un po di libertà valori
ebbene in questa classe l'esperienza
della bioetica evidente mi ha permesso
anche di continuare ad appassionarmi ma
anche a promuovere quello che il dialogo
interreligioso perché io da credente
musulmano velata credo fermamente nella
fede e quindi ci tengo anche a
condividere la mia fede con altre
persone ma anche di promuovere il
dialogo tra le diverse fedi e c'è un
ricordo che mi è rimasto impresso di
quando ero piccola facevo forse seconda
media prima media
mia madre mi aveva scritto all'estate
ragazzi vicino a casa nella parrocchia
dalla santa caterina a torino ve la
immaginate ragazza musulmana fare le
seta ragazzine parrocchia si fa male
esiste e stato bellissimo stupendo e a
questo ricordo i suoi letizia e don
antonio che tutte le mattine ci facevano
andare in questa stanza enorme piena di
ragazzini e ragazzine che appunto non
vedevano l'ora di cominciare l'attività
all'estate ragazzi però la mattina c'era
un momento di preghiera
tra l'altro ci sono alcune preghiere che
io ricordo tuttora perché mi sono grosse
impressa in quel momento non sapevo che
cosa fare torno a casa e dico a mia
mamma non io cosa devo fare quando i
miei amici pregano
mia madre mi ha dato una risposta che vi
giuro
ce l'ho nel cuore mi ha detto deve
rimanere in silenzio
ascoltava i tre amici pregare e
rispettare la loro preghiera se vuoi
puoi pregare però non ad alta voce
perché non li devi disturbare io sono
cresciuto con quell insegnamento il
rispetto
quei famosi rispetto che tutti
pretendono ma pochi danno
e poi non poteva non parlare di film
dei miei film preferiti into the wild
in questo vince una citazione
meravigliosa che voglio leggervi nella
vita quello che conta non essere forti
ma sentirsi forti se vuoi qualcosa
veramente
datti da fare prendila io mi sono data
fa nappa da fare scusate mi son presa
quello che è mio ci sono anche
tantissime cose che voglio fare la vita
voglio girare il mondo voglio raccontare
il mondo con i miei occhi vuole
continuare a promuovere il dialogo
interreligioso interculturale e voglio
continua ad essere quella che sono
questi sono tre ingredienti che hanno un
po caratterizzato quello che il mio
percorso il coraggio e rispetto alla
perseveranza il coraggio di essere se
stessi perché io per tre anni non avevo
il coraggio di essere me stessa l'ho
data vinta una ragazza che mi abolì data
che non fa niente di me
perché quando ci penso di cova perché
l'ho fatto eppure l'ho fatto pazienza me
ne farò una ragione
però adesso sono me stessa e non
permetterò mai a nessuno di farmi
sentire diversa
rispetto nei miei confronti
i confronti di quella che sono io e nei
confronti dell'altra persona
e poi c'è sempre con la storia che vi ho
raccontato di mia madre che mi ha
trasmesso rispetto da quando ero piccola
mi ha detto devi rispettare le persone
rispetto alla testa ma rispetterà anche
lea t se vuoi essere rispettata
e poi c'è la perseveranza e io so de
coccio sono testarda se mi metto in
testa una cosa è quella mi definiscono
che non scheggia impazzita perché
viaggio tanto e non so stare ferma come
adesso appunto
e poi c'è la legacy non so quanti di voi
conoscono cosa significa legacy in
italiano possiamo tradurlo come
proprietà quando si parla di lega se si
parla sempre quasi sempre di proprietà o
comunque della cito di un qualcosa che
tu lasci agli altri l'eredità ad esempio
fa parte della nostra lega sì ma la lega
siano si limita solo questo la lega sia
anche tanto altro la lega si è quello
che tu lasci alle persone che possono
essere i tuoi valori in valori che
trasmette agli altri perché cosa le
persone ti ricorderanno ecco io su
questo palco vi ho trasmesso quella che
la mia legacy che la mia storia il mio
percorso di vita i miei falli niente le
mie paure e le insicurezze ma anche le
mie rivincite fatto che sono me stessa
che mi racconto sono qui chi parla di
bullismo senza piangere e credetemi è un
grande obiettivo raggiunto in questo
momento io non glielo chiederà voi che
cos'è la vostra legacy qual è la vostra
legacy ci avete mai pensato che cosa
lascerete voi alle persone che cosa
lasciate le persone che cosa
ricorderanno le persone quando andrete
nell'aldilà detta così sembra un po
brutta
però è importante pensare a quale la
nostra legacy il quale il messaggio che
noi vogliamo dare alle persone
perché quando pensi alla tua legacy ti
fai
un auto riflessione di quello che fa e
di quello che sei e di quello che lasci
soprattutto di quello che semini
io credo di aver seminato tanto in
questo mondo e spero di lasciare
un'impronta anche più di una nelle
persone e anche in questa terra
qual è la vostra legacy grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]